[Musik]
und herzlich willkommen zu einem neuen
blog habe seit sage und schreibe 200
nicht mehr geflogen
es tut so gut euch jetzt wieder
mitzunehmen häufig zu beobachten wir
haben heute einen kirsch massiv an
streuselkuchen gedreht das zeige ich
euch mal der sieht so unscheinbar aus
ist aber einfach nur lecker und ich
liebe diese kuchen die mit der zeit
einfach noch saftiger werden wir es
gedreht und genau jetzt haben wir hunger
daher habe ich mein herz aufgetaut und
mache jetzt öfter wahrscheinlich kräfte
mit kartoffeln et cetera aus dem prof
und in dem ich mich jetzt einfach mal
mit weil das rezept gibt es ja schon das
ist ja dass kohle also ich kann ich das
rezept ich auch gerne noch verlinken
dann könnt ihr das eher nach machen
wieso habt ruhig aus der übung zu haben
heute keine blog schwer gemacht jetzt
erst mal das hackfleisch vorbereiten ich
hatte leider keine frischen zwiebeln das
kommt ja auch welt informieren das habe
ich jetzt zwiebel granulat mag ich mich
so gerne im fleisch aber egal jetzt noch
ein bisschen paniermehl noch einen
einsatz um nachher und dann schön kneten
[Musik]
es hat sich einiges getan werde jetzt
eine stunde später kam sie in dieser
ecke macht gerade die fotos von dem tier
schmerzen streuselkuchen
ich hab auch und besser bist einfach ja
obwohl ich will meinen finger sauber
gemacht hat wo es um brillen putztuch ja
ich denke das ist besser gesagt ich sage
ich meinen tisch und streuselkuchen wie
haben sie den fotografierten nach essen
wir und dann ist der tag ja auch schon
wieder rum also der sieht echt
unscheinbar aus mannschaft aber ja du
hast das du bist hier einen schuldigen
ich mal sagen
das licht ist gerade schatten
jetzt wollte ich gerade essen braucht
tun das kann ich anschneiden und wieder
zu unser magen geknurrt noch ein
weilchen
der marktfokus und weiß dass nichts das
hat was nichts ist schön hat das also
dieses messer begeisterte zwei jahren um
gelungen seit zwei jahren ich liebe das
ich schneide kein kuchen ohne dieses
messer an vw knusprig streusel sind die
suche oder soll jetzt aber endlich wir
haben's mittlerweile 22 uhr
meine freundin war gerade noch ganz kurz
offenen café hier weil sie in der nähe
war und ich weiß nicht warum aber wenn
freunde da sind oder wenn ich mit
freunden bin dann kann die kamera
draufhalten ich weiß nicht dann ist man
so in dem moment und denkt nicht dran zu
bloggen aber solche ich auch zeigen also
wir unterhalten uns ja und trinkt einen
kaffee dabei es gibt ganz erlauben die
mal unordentlich zu lassen weil wir ja
dass der arbeitsort von uns so ein
bisschen auch und wir müssen bauern
wieder film daher muss ich mich da jetzt
noch ranmachen noch nicht am liebsten
schlafen würde aber ich mache das jetzt
noch schnell bei mir war jetzt in
letzter zeit echt blöd ich hatte die
heftigste augenentzündung die ich je
gesehen habe ich hatte nicht nur
die trend entzündung sondern auch
gerstenkorn also wenn ist eigentlich
schon gerecht hat kann auch das
gerstenkorn dazu es hat mich voll aus
der bahn geworfen weil ich war
körperlich fit konnte aber nichts machen
weil immer im beruf brauche ich also
muss ich vor der kamera sein und euch
rezepte mit seiner entzündung zu zeigen
ist einfach nicht schmackhaft eines sehr
sehr negativen aspekte dass man wenn man
sowas hat einfach nicht weiter arbeiten
kann und es ist ja nicht so dass die
aufgaben sich häufenden sondern die
video tage vergehen
die upload tage vergeben wir brauchen ja
oder wir möchten ja weiterhin videos im
petto haben
das ist so ja es hat mich jetzt voll aus
der bahn geworfen daher müssen jetzt
richtig gas geben können uns eigentlich
gar keine freizeit erlauben und ich
glaube ich werde euch dass man dem bild
zeigen ich zeige euch doch mal damit ihm
aber ich habe mich auch in der zeit zwei
wochen gar nicht blicken lassen auf
installation einfach so heftig fand ich
den geruch als ich und ich wollte das
einfach nicht ich wollte mich einfach so
in der story nicht sehen man zeigt ja
auch dass man echt so man sagt ja auch
wirklich nur das was man zeigen möchte
und jedes instagram profil ist ja nur
das was man auch von sich preisgeben
möchte also man kreiert sich sein
instagram profil ihr so wie man damit im
reinen ist quasi und ich war in dem
moment nicht im reinen mit mir und
wollte mir so nicht zeigen aber ich
zeige euch jetzt nachher gerne mal ein
bild was ich mit meinem handy gemacht
also jetzt nicht erschrecken das war
mein auge und ich hatte es hier komplett
offen also wenn eigentlich das lied hier
oben sein musste war das die ganze zeit
auf der hör ich konnte es nicht weiter
öffnen als das und hier ist jetzt
natürlich selber drauf deswegen glänzte
setzung bisschen und alsdann besserung
in sicht war ging es dann soweit auf war
aber immer noch dick wegen dem
gerstenkorn hier also ich glaube ich
könnte jetzt verstehen warum warum ich
absolut keine videos drehen konnte das
ding ist einfach wenn man selbstständig
ist und eben nichts machen kann
das heißt ich konnte ein auftrag auf
denen ich mich super gefreut hab' nicht
ausführen den musste ich ablehnen ich
konnte meine videos nicht drehen andere
sachen sind auf der strecke geblieben
das ist wenn man wenn man wirklich
selbstständig ist darauf angewiesen ist
dass man gesund ist schätzt man umso
mehr wenn man dann wirklich fit ist und
nachdem das passiert ist
und ich danach auch noch total blöd
würde ich dann wirklich krank gott sei
dank ging das dann auch nach drei tagen
wieder irgendwo es ist ja auch
verantwortung also ich trage die
verantwortung für die videos die ihr
erwartet für die kooperationspartner für
für mich selber mittlerweile achte ich
auf einer ganz anderen art und weise auf
mich wie youtube oder generell youtuber
ist die kalte jahreszeit hochsaison hat
ihr dann viel einschaltet so ist einfach
so sagen und im sommer ist keiner
irgendwie am handy ich genauso wenig und
deshalb ist da nicht so schlimm noch mal
ausfällt okay ich kann ich muss dir die
küche aufräumen
das heißt ich mache ich meine zeit reif
war ein linker linker platz ist den
leuten bei den augen gezeigt brauchst du
das weil ich sonst wieder flott zu
machen
jeweils denn für dich so mich so zu
sehen ist das war also das beschreiben
was ich am anfang hatte ich mich
geborgen und dann die schule große kunst
also die kurzfassung die kurz versuchen
war mir nicht weh getan weil ich muss
seine kopf hast ja noch sagen wo sie
richtig drauf bock hatte ich konnte es
leider nicht machen zu machen
nein genau auf jeden fall durch die
echte runtergezogen aber ich war
natürlich für sie da und haben sie habe
ich dann wieder aufgebaut
ich habe so lange dieses auge angucken
bis das nicht mal weg gibt denn und dann
war es doch einmal etwas weg aber es
hier ich sagen kann ich mache genau
gemacht haben soll ich muss jetzt im
zeitraffer die küche auch um hast du
lust mitzuwirken in meinem zeitraffer
film
ich muss es wieder schnell an diese
ausreden da ich rauskam schneidet gerade
voll aber wir sind noch nicht so woche
wirklich muss das alles hinter mir haben
ja wir sind nächste woche weg darüber
rede ich morgen mit euch da habe ich mal
ein gesprächsstoff titanic gerade
aufgeräumt und schon wieder ordentlich
weil ich jetzt für den dreh morgen doch
noch was vorbereiten wollte einmal
meinen hefeteig den dass sich im
kühlschrank gehen und von der pudding
habe ich auch schon vorbereitet aber
dann habe ich meine ruhe und hat für
morgen keine wartezeit
jetzt gehe ich schlafen ist morgen
guten morgen ein neuer tag
jetzt gehen wir mal zusammen in die
küche mit meinen kunden badelatschen und
ich hätte schwören können ich habe hier
gestern aufgeräumt also ihr seid doch
meine zweigen habe ich hier nicht
gestern aufgeräumt was ist denn hier
wieder los also werde ich jetzt hier
nochmal ordnung schaffen jetzt aber für
den dreh weil beträgen leicht ich will
die lobeck keks rolle machen die ich
letztes mal ausprobiert habe das haben
alle dinge sehen die wir auf instagram
folgen und die vanille händchen den
hilfe tag habe ich ja gestern
vorbereitet der sich schon aufgegangen
im kühlschrank wenn ihr den nämlich
nicht in den kühlschrank und über nacht
dann fängt er an zu stinken und dann
könnt ihr nicht mehr gebraucht und daher
könnte sowas immer am vortag vorbereiten
und dann mit der kalten führung also im
kühlschrank gehen lassen so und jetzt
mache ich hier immer ein bisschen
klatsch mache ein bisschen ordnung muss
der halter dazu kommen und dann fehlen
wir
[Musik]
so jetzt wird gefilmt also wir sind
beide stark klar haben sie bis zu
startklar sehr gut wenn wir die kamera
mal laufen lassen 1 2 traf sie den zunge
verschluckt wir drehen uns beim film ok
jetzt seht ihr ein paar
zeitrafferaufnahmen wie das hinter den
kulissen abläuft 21
[Musik]
also wir sind noch mitten im video
schneidet gerade die rolle an wir
überlegen aber jetzt schon wie wir das
thumbnail machen müssen weil das einfach
das aller aller wichtigste wenn er nicht
gerade follower sei dann ist das
heimrecht für die dann neu dazu kommen
zum kriterium klicke ich jetzt drauf
oder nicht und da habe ich mir etwas
ganz bestimmtes überlegt gucken wir
etwas durchsetzen können und werte ich
das ganze muss noch fotografiert werden
und sehen werden noch aufgenommen so
haben sie bitte schnell fotografien und
führen damit ich den da trinken kann der
gehört mir
den habe ich mit viel liebe gemacht für
mich schnell fotos machen videos machen
dann trinke ich das hier ach so
natürlich das trinken kann natürlich
nicht ist
und dann machen wir weiter mit dem
zweiten rezepte sind die familien
standen vanille stangen mit ich die ganz
ganz stark angefragt wurden aber als
erstes wird das huhn und zwar das essen
von gestern muss sich hier noch
aufgewärmt hat sie jetzt erstmal
verspeist und dann drehen wir das zweite
video
[Musik]
wir haben es jetzt 1937 das video ist
fertig also ich hab mein auto gesprochen
und morgen bei tageslicht machen wir
dann fotos sind die entziehen und es ist
noch pures chaos hier überall ich weiß
dass man nicht gleich das verschiebe ich
erstmal weil ich habe noch 20 minuten um
schnelle lichterketten zu besorgen heute
samstag abend und ich heute voll gerne
die wohnung schmücken wenn es im winter
wo alles so dunkel und trist ist habe
ich mir gedacht geschichte die wohnung
auch mit ein paar lichterketten und die
gehe ich jetzt ganz schnell besorgen
[Musik]
ich lege das nur kurz ab ganz vorsichtig
und diese schon wieder weiter hieß
nämlich noch nach kaufland also zu
kaufland nachkaufen
wie auch immer ich muss jetzt noch dahin
und muss ein passant einkaufen und erst
mal ganz schnell im schnelldurchlauf
[Musik]
ich bin nur durch den wind im wahrsten
sinne so bin ich da gibt es mal ein
käufer aus mehr passiert nicht also
spannend der wird glaube ich nicht so
direkt man in die tat umgesetzt das ist
neu also die laterne nicht aber das
licht habe steht die lichterkette das
ist auch alt schon viel besser
also jetzt nicht müde und heute bist
echt nicht viel passiert also so
alltäglich videos drehen einkaufen
aufräumen also ich sag ja die tage sind
immer so mal sind sie voll spannender
was ansteht und mal ist einfach nur
routine aber ich bin heute morgen dafür
auch noch mal mit guten 8 guten morgen
guten morgen sagen morgen ihr könnt auch
die kamera die kamera läuft so lange
bist du kommst und alle warten ja jetzt
sehen wir was mir wichtig heute so mich
bewegt ist heute dass wir das 23 23 sind
geplant am 22
das dritte ist ein piano rezept was war
heute zu mittag essen zu schaffen würde
dann schaffen wir drei haben sich
wir schauen in mailand tut weh ich mache
jetzt einen cut geschafft
diese früchte kammerscheid muss ich nur
noch die reste hier einmal aufräumen und
dann wenn fotos geschossen die wir
gestern nicht geschafft haben es schon
zu dunkel war oder set nachher fotos in
dem kasten haben sich jetzt erstmal eine
vanille stange und mich ja erstmal eine
den riss packe ich jetzt hier ein kannst
du dir heute abend mit dem wenn du zu
deinen kumpels haben ein café später
jetzt werden wir endlich videos drehen
das haben wir als ein relikt und jetzt
geht an zu filmen so wäre mit zwei
rezepte abgefilmt eins davon ist ein
weiteres appiano gericht polo bekannte
oder so lecker und ihr könnt es so
einfach selber machen aber das video
wird ja bald online koop vielleicht ist
es auch schon online wenn den block gut
ist die moll conti nun werden sie kalt
aber ist nicht schlimm würde verlassen
jetzt die wohnungen können sie nicht
mehr sehen wenn wir gehen jetzt hat ein
treffen mit seinen freunden das ihr
schon länger fest und ich habe mir das
war ich habe auch keine lust mehr hier
zu hause zu hocken
ich muss mal an die luft und ich gehe
mal meine eltern besuchen einfach so
ganz spontan
ich habe hier auch hab ja auch was
schönes mitgebracht ja nicht mit leeren
händen das war tolle dass er immer alles
schön mitnehmen können was wir drehen
will
schlüssel hallo was du steckst du da
die höheren gestanden es ist doch gut
dass im gepäck also keiner geht leer aus
das ist dann auch wissen das ist der
klassiker richtig süß die konversation
zwischen hammer und meiner mutter
das müsst ihr euch mal anhören habe ich
deine stimme gehört habe ich mich
gefreut
ehrlich gesagt habe ich vermisst ich
habe ihr gesagt wie telefonie mit ihr
aber haben sie hören wir gar nichts die
einmal vorbeikommen einmal sehen ich
habe dich vermisst
alles gute danke durch zurück
richtig wir waren am anfang nachdem ihr
ausgezogen
jede woche unsere eltern besuchen
gegangen und jetzt also winter seien es
zeit ist bei fußball bei youtube an
hochsaison
und da ist schon morgens bis abends
umdrehen und schaffen es erst wirklich
8 9 uhr jemanden besuchen zu gehen in
der messe stellt man halt ne also die
mannschaft ja die hühner nicht gerade um
die ecke ist das problem
meine eltern wohnen noch ein bisschen
mehr unterhalt dieses treffen mit seinen
freunden was seit zwei wochen feststeht
und da hab ich dann gehe ich dahin weil
sie nicht sicher schon heimlich zu
nehmen
übrigens den hausschlüssel den habe ich
nie wirklich abgegeben
selbst sind wir auch schon wieder zu
hause und ich sitze gerade im
arbeitszimmer haben noch ein bisschen
was am pc gemacht das ist jetzt auch
schon kurz nach zwölf also ich
geschlafen aber ich wollte euch noch
etwas zeigen und zwar das ist mein
hochzeitsfoto album
ich bin also als ich eben das ist vor
ein paar tagen bekommen ich hätte das
schon viel viel eher bekommen aber die
liebe karte die die fotos gemacht habe
ich wollte dir einfach persönlich mit
ihr treffen ich hätte gesagt kommen wir
treffen uns dann persönlich welche marke
total gern erzählte sie und ihre
schwester auf einer hochzeit kennen
lernen will ihre schwester die parierte
meine hochzeitstorte gemacht und die
karten fotografien ich wollte mich
unbedingt mit ihr persönlich treffen
aber irgendwie hatte ich nie zeit und
ihn dann hat es nicht gepasst sondern
haben wir besser ist es egal sie meinte
ich schick dir das für post und dann
sehen wir uns ja irgendwann trotzdem und
es ist halt angekommen ich also schon
vor ein paar tagen vielmehr soll es
schon drei vier mal angeguckt und müssen
so schöne bilder ich zeige euch gerne
mal einen einblick wenn ihr mögt also
die hochzeit ist jetzt so ziemlich genau
sieben monate her also 29 haben haben
sie endlich geheiratet und so nach
sieben monaten noch mal die bilder zu
sehen das ist schon echt ein schönes
gefühl ich kann doch nicht alle bilder
zeigen weil es sind natürlich auch
personen dabei die möchten vielleicht
gar nicht ins internet da muss man auch
verständnis für haben und ich zeige euch
jetzt auch mal ein paar eindrücke
da seht ihr eine überglückliche kiki
hier der moment als ich dann das erste
mal gesehen hat also das war wirklich
seinen blick das ist jetzt keine
schauspielerei so hat er geguckt und ich
habe den haben sie noch nie süßes
lächeln sehen richtig knuffig hier
hatten auch super wetter die fotos haben
bei uns im garten gemacht also richtig
praktisch das sind meine eltern das
finde ich auch richtig süß das bild
richtig knuffig einzelner
lieblingsbilder unser plan für den tag
das war wirklich total strukturiert also
das timing war sehr sehr eng getaktet
und unser plan war dieser von mir auch
so durchgeführt dass hansa erstmal kommt
nachdem ich fertig geschminkt war und
fertiggemacht war zugegen
35 kam der hammer alleine sind bruder
team natürlich gefahrene kam erst mal
allein und dann haben wir es mal ganz in
ruhe unsere fotos im garten gemacht und
dass wir eben gerade das foto mit dem
ersten blick da kam mir halt vormittags
wenn es dann noch mal gegangen hab noch
mal die zeit genutzt und ein bisschen zu
entspannen und dann kam er gegen 16.30
mit seiner ganzen familie und natürlich
mit stimmung also das schöne ist wir
sind wirklich zwei kulturen die
aufeinanderprallen also hamza der arab
herkunft ist hat natürlich arabische
musik gemacht also die hat ein
arabisches stimmung und das sieht man
dann auf dem hochzeitsvideo er wird halt
aus dem haus geholt mit arabischer
stimmung mit mit der buga und sowas und
als er dann bei mir ankommen meinen
eltern weil dann mehr so hat und dieses
barroso
ich muss sich das am ehesten
reinschreiben und das ist ich kenne das
auch türkische aber auf jeden fall als
für außenstehende ist es so ok ja die
sind halt beide aus dem orient ist das
ist gleich aber nein ist und solche
unterschiede in unseren kulturen das ist
unglaublich
trotzdem welt schön dass die familien
sich so gut verstehen und die sich so
respektieren und das ist einfach ein
wunderschönes gefühl jetzt zeige ich
euch die fotos die entstanden sind als
daneben haben sie mit seiner ganzen
truppe zu uns kam und mich als braut
dann quasi von zu hause abgeholt hat
hier habe ich den hunger gesehen das
bild gefällt mir auch richtig gut also
die karte ja nicht die schönsten momente
festgehalten sieht man also das bild
gefällt mir richtig gut weil hier sind
man die flöte die halt eben unsere musik
so ein bisschen symbolisiert und ja hier
sind wir gerade wirklich dann raus wir
haben hier das ist wenn meine eltern zu
hause das wohnzimmer der ganz große
schiebetür und hier sind wir dann zum
garten rausgegangen kann garten noch ein
bisschen getanzt sind das macht sein
habe ich mich von meinen eltern
verabschiedet das war ein bisschen
emotional weil das ist dieser moment
okay die braut ist aus dem haus raus bis
zum elternhaus und bei uns ist es ja
wirklich so dass ich die erst dann
ausziehen wenn wir auch heiraten und das
war echt emotional
also hier war aber wieder partystimmung
also wirklich achterbahn der gefühle
hier haben sich total feiern lassen von
seinen kollegen vor dem vor dem saal
genau also es echt ein auf und ab der
gefühle gewesen dem tag
sie sind gerade in den saal reingekommen
haben schon alle gewartet ab 23 uhr ging
dann der hannah abend los ich habe auf
der hochzeit meine hannah zeremonie gab
die hannah zeremonie ist total
traditionell und wird eigentlich ein
paar tage oder eine woche vor der
hochzeit gefeiert
ursprünglich sogar eigentlich nur die
braut mit weiblichen freunden verwandten
und bekannten
und dann dann hat die hände mit henna
mal das wären traurige lieder gespielt
die mutter verabschiedet sich dann auch
noch mal so ein bisschen also es ist
sehr emotional auf jeden fall für mich
als einfach in vielen hinsichten viel
viel viel vorteilhafter und einfacher
meine hände zeremonie auf der hochzeit
zu machen
das habe ich jetzt so auch schon ein
paar mal erlebt und ich bereue es nicht
also das ist wirklich eine sache die ich
absolut nicht bereue ich hab dann
wirklich nur ein abend gehabt mit
hochzeit und händler feier und es ist so
dass man sich dann also die post zieht
sich dann traditionell rot an und das
habe ich dann auch gemacht also ich habe
mich während meiner hochzeit einmal
umgezogen nicht im brautkleid nach hause
gegangen also das war für mich auch ganz
entspannt und das war dann wirklich so
nach der innern zur emo nie war das war
dann wirklich auch zu der arm langsam
vorbei so gegen null ohren wenn du noch
so die engste familie im sei also das
war schon als ich bereue nichts also
schon als echt in ordnung so ist aber
auch sehr emotional vor allem auch für
meine mama was er ganz klar ist und der
hansa ist dann halt
wir haben soll hatte jetzt hier so ein
foto was mir total gut gefällt während
ich mich umgezogen hat erhält auf dem
stuhl gewartet und um ihn herum man
hunderte von menschen als unsere
hochzeit war riesig dazu muss ich sagen
geplant waren 700 leute man rechnet
immer damit dass 50 bis 100 leute auch
mal absagen aber so plant 700 leute
gekommen sind 850 aber das ist ein
anderes thema ich kann gerne einmal mehr
so in die details gehen wenn er das
möchte ich weiß ja nicht wie das thema
gerade bei euch ankommt
aber ich weiß dass das interesse riesig
ist wenn ihr möchtet dass ich meine
riskiert dann schreib mir das gerne in
die kommentare ich jetzt noch mal auf
und zeigt euch jetzt noch mal ein paar
bilder der hannah zeremonie während der
hochzeitsfeier das ist das bild von dem
sich gerade erzählt habe daher haben sie
gewartet und also ziemlich lang auch als
er meinte er sagt dazu ich finde das
einfach so süß das ist so ein gelungenes
bild branche hier sieht man es auch
nochmal genau und dann kann ich halt
ganz in rot und ja ich möchte jetzt
nicht so viel zeit ist es doch schon
ziemlich privaten ich weiß nicht wie
andere dazustehen öffnet seine mama die
hat kein problem aber ich weiß nicht wie
andere dazu stehen wenn man sie jetzt im
blog zeigt also ich persönlich würde das
ja auch nicht ungefragt wollen wir haben
sagt ja auch ein bisschen herab bekommen
das ist meine beste freundin die das
gemacht hat für uns ja und so endet das
wunderschöne fotoalbum mit dem hannah
abend beziehungsweise der herner
zeremonie auf einer hochzeitsfeier ja
also richtig richtig schöne erinnerung
und mit diesen schönen bildern verlasse
ich euch jetzt beziehungsweise der block
endet ihr übrigens falls ihr euch
wundert warum hat sie jetzt hier einfach
mal einer dieser schrank in ihrem
arbeitszimmer der hat halt nicht ins
schlafzimmer passt da versuche ich aber
glaube ich schon mal zählt und im
schlafzimmer habe ich meinen kleinen
kleiderschrank aus meinem jugendzimmer
also es ist alles nicht so es ist alles
nicht so optimal also ich werde auch
hier das arbeitszimmer einmal komplett
entrümpelt verändern und vielleicht kann
ich euch dass er im nächsten block
zeigen wenn die möchte oder im
übernächsten wie ich hier mein
arbeitszimmer verändert vielleicht könnt
ihr euch ja auch ein paar tipps abholen
pcs hauptbüro oder arbeitsraum jetzt
verabschiede ich mich von euch freue
mich wenn ihr bis hierhin dran geblieben
seid und ja wenn ihr mehr blogs sehen
möchte dann schreibt mir gerne ich weiß
immer nie
wenn ich so ein blog drehe ob ich jetzt
habe ich es spannendes material oder war
dass er so alltag mäßig stellt sich
immer erst heraus wenn ich das wirklich
am pc schneide und ich einfach mal
gespannt dass ich jetzt hier für euch
gefilmt habe
wenn es euch gefällt dann freut mich
natürlich gehören wir und lesen in den
kommentaren von einander
also tschüss ihr lieben klar und wir
haben sie so tiefer spielen kein ende in
aussicht
ich hasse fifa-boss
[Musik]